ils s'appellent les gardiens de
la galaxie il y a des voleurs les chasseurs de primes
et les négligés ce n'est pas un
film de super-héros typique que nous rencontrons tous en
prison et nous finissons par nous lier pendant une
évasion de prison qui était un très bon plan
ici couette c'est le seul humain dans  ce
monde fou qu'il n'a pas comme
une force surhumaine ou la capacité de
voler mais il utilise sa ruse et son
charme pour se sortir de la situation
il y a ma planète confortable hors-la-loi
Billy the Kid Bonnie et Clyde
John Stamos sonne comme un endroit que je
voudrais  j'aime poursuivre Jax est un avocat mais
il est tellement drôle que les
métaphores vont passer par-dessus rien
ne me dépasse mes réflexes sont trop
rapides j'attraperais Gomorrhe a un cœur
d'or même si elle est mortelle et
très très dure n'apprenez pas l'un des  mon
groupe de problèmes est l'un des personnages les plus étranges et les plus
intéressants
que Marvel ait jamais mis en scène.
gs comme combien cela va faire mal
ils se réunissent pour sauver la galaxie
il y a beaucoup d'humour dans celui-ci et
beaucoup de cœur Wow
il n'y a rien de tel c'est sûr que
notre monde fait face à une
menace imparable envoyer les Gardiens
ouais